*Clock tower sounds*
- Bonjour!
- bonjour!
- bonjour! - bonjour!
♪There goes the baker
with his tray, like always♪
♪The same old bread
and rolls to sell♪
♪Every morning
just the same♪
♪Since the morning
that we came♪
♪To this poor
provincial town♪
- Good morning, Belle!
- Good morning
Monsieur Jean!
have you lost
something again?
- Well, I believe I have
problem is
I... I can't remember what
Oh well, I'm sure
it'll come to me
Where are you off to?
- To return to this book to Père Robert
it's about two lovers fair Verona
- Sounds boring
♪Look there she goes,♪
♪That girl is strange, no question♪
♪Dazed and distracted, can't you tell?♪
♪Never part of any crowd♪
♪ 'Cause her head's up
on some cloud♪
♪No denying she's
a funny girl that Belle♪
- My dear Belle
you're so ahead of your time
this is a small village
- You are the most gorgeous
thing I've ever seen
nobody deserves you
- And, it's small-minded as well
but small also means safe
- I've come for my father!
- He's a thief
- Come into the light
I will escape,
I promise
- Look, a girl!
- Who said that?
- Hello!
- You can talk?
- Well, of course
- that's all he ever does!
- How lovely to make
your acquaintance
- Wanna see me do a trick?
- What happens when
the last petal falls?
- The master remains
a beast forever
- And we become antiques
- What did you do to it?
- Nothing
- Get out of here! go!!!
- You have to help me
you have to stand
ON
MARCH 17
- If she is the one―
who'll break the spell
you must finally learn to love
- Have you really read
every one of these books?
- Some of them
are in Greek
[pleasant smile]
EXPERIENCE THE TALE
AS OLD AS TIME
Kill the beast!!!
Disney
BEAUTY AND THE BEAST
MARCH 17
TICKETS AVAILABLE NOW
Disney BEAUTY AND THE BEAST
IN THEATRES MARCH 17